[Music]
we've been waiting a long time for this
now it's finally here I'm Dan Ackerman
with a first look at a lien where steam
machine runs an operating system called
steam OS valve is the company that runs
the steam online game store they've also
created cool games like portal and
half-life and they've invited all sorts
of PC hardware makers to make boxes that
run steam OS and the first big one to be
released is going to be the Alienware
steam machine it should be out in
November for 450 dollars and for that
you get a basic looking box that's
essentially a PC and a console box core
i3 CPU custom NVIDIA GPU but most
importantly this guy right here the
steam controller so that the steam
controller Val sent out to reimagine how
you controlled games so it's got these
two pans on it these two sort of almost
touch pads combined with one stick and a
bunch of buttons and then some triggers
and paddles this pant especially works
almost like moving a mouse on a mousepad
or can work kind of like a traditional
old-school trackball if that's what you
want there are a lot of setup options
and frankly in in hands-on use it works
differently in different games bedrooms
some not as good and others so here's a
really good example in BioShock Infinite
I walk around the left stick like you
would with a gamepad and then I use the
right pad to look around and took a
little getting used to I actually have
to go in and tweak the sensitivity level
on the controls we can actually go into
the configure the game controller
section and you can see how the
controller here is is set up and then
you can choose different configurations
either recommended ones or ones provided
by the community and as more people get
this system hopefully they'll come up
with their own key bindings and settings
that work and upload them it actually
works for here to go out with things
like strategy games like SIF 5 where you
really do have a lot of fine control to
zoom all over the map and then take
control of individual units but you'll
also have the flexibility of using a
mouse where you can really just very
easily scroll around and then you can
take the right stick and you can just
move the cursor anywhere so Team
Fortress 2 is a hugely popular
multiplayer game and it's one of the
ones like dota 2 that you can actually
play on steamos and it's one of the ones
where these team
even though it's a first-person shooter
actually worked really well so the
controls don't exactly map one-to-one
with what you'd expect from using a
traditional gamepad or using a keyboard
and mouse you have to kind of figure out
exactly which command works with which
button and which trigger and which
paddle on here so it takes a little bit
of getting used to it
the real wrench in the system is there's
a second version of this Alienware a box
call the Alienware alpha almost the same
exact hardware but it runs Windows 10
and comes with a xbox controller instead
of the scene controller and that lets
you play all the games you can plan in
here plus the thousands of other Steam
games that are Windows only and the
strange thing is that box in this box
cost exactly the same so if you want to
be adventurous and be kind of a pioneer
in gaming then maybe consider the
Alienware a steam machine version if
you're a traditionalist and you want to
play upcoming games like let's say
Fallout 4 then take a look at the nearly
identical handling where alpha I'm Dan
Ackerman and that is the Alienware steam
machine with steam OS
[Music]